ein einfacher rhythmus und eine
jahrhunderte alte melodie verändern
alles für nation evans ist ein
sogenanntes shanti mit dem seemannslied
enterte schotter europaweit die spitze
der musikcharts
es ist unglaublich als ob ein traum wahr
geworden wäre und fassbar und ich warte
die ganze zeit darauf jeden moment aus
diesem traum aufzuwachen
denn bis vor kurzem treffen evans in
airdrie einer schottischen stadt glasgow
noch briefe aus nebenher singt er songs
nach und lädt sie auf der videoplattform
tik tok auf wunsch seiner follower
covert er auch shantys sowie liefere
johnny und andere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ende 2020 der überraschungserfolg seine
version des neuseeländischen walfang
liedes zoomen com wird ein viraler hits
ich dachte ich lade wellermann hoch
damit meine follower und ich spaß haben
und mitsingen können und dann geht es
mit dem nächsten lied weiter
nie im leben hätte ich gedacht dass es
ein song wird der die charts auf der
ganzen welt stimmt es ist nicht zu
fassen
er löst eine welle aus und viele machen
mit das internet wird mit dem women
geradezu überflutet
während der korona pandemie trifft der
song den nerv vieler menschen denn das
seemannslied handelt von der einsamkeit
der seeleute
der song kommt genau in einer zeit in
der alle zuhause festsitzen ausgebrannt
sind und ihre freunde nicht sehen können
jeder kann mitmachen mitsingen mit den
füßen stampfen in die hände klatschen
oder ein instrument zu spielen
man kann um singen oder etwas vorführen
wenn man den jeder ist dabei und das
zaubert den leuten ein lächeln auf die
lippen
für gute laune sorgten solche lieder
schon ab dem 15 jahrhundert als
seefahrer monatelang auf den meeren
unterwegs waren
in den so genannten call and response
songs also ruf und antwort liedern sagen
der shanty man eine strophe vor und dann
stimmte der rest der mannschaft beim
refrain mit ein
im digitalen zeitalter sind die internet
community mit durch die duett funktion
bei tik tok entstehen so mehrstimmige
seemanns chor
[Musik]
sogar prominente wie die us
violinistinnen sterling oder der
britische gitarrist brian may werden vom
shanty h erfasst
[Musik]
ich war sprachlos als ich herausfand des
brian may ronan keating und gary barlow
mitmachen
all diese leute zusehen wie sie scheint
ist segen und sich einbringen das ist
einfach wunderbar
ich hätte nie gedacht dass so etwas mal
passieren würde
mit einem plattenvertrag in der tasche
kündigt er seinen job als postbote und
konzentriert sich nun auf seine
musikkarriere
gerade arbeitet er an seinem ersten
album auch eine tour ist in planung
[Musik]
wenn alles scheitern sollte werde ich
mir gerne wieder einen anderen job
suchen und werde das als erfahrung
mitnehmen und ich werde weiter gitarre
spielen und singen
das macht keinen unterschied für mich
doch nur wer es wagt hat eine chance auf
erfolg
seinen traum von der musik leben zu
können ist neben seinen großen schritten
näher gekommen
[Musik]